it started to pace towards my bed I
could not even describe to you the
motion that used to walk hello and
welcome to all daint a sleepy pasta or
our stories dreamed to perfection with a
wave of nightmares and terror my name is
Susie and I will be your somnambulist
in this episode I'll also be joined by
the dark somnium dreams are a lot like
death we know how and when they happen
but we'll never fully understand them
this time we'll be exploring a few
creepy accounts of dreams or more
accurately nightmares let's tuck right
in number one
wake up syndrome do you ever wake up in
a hotel or at a friend's house and for
those first few seconds of consciousness
not know exactly where you are like it
takes a few moments for you to realize
that you aren't in your own bed but
you've gone on vacation or that you've
passed out in a buddy's guest room this
always used to happen to me when I would
go away to summer camp as a kid it would
happen during the first week or so I
would wake up thinking I was in my own
bed at least until I opened my eyes and
came to the realization then I was in a
cabin miles away from home that same
thing would always happen during those
first couple of days home from camp I
would pop out of bed ready to go for a
hike or a kayak only to discover that my
mind had been playing tricks on me again
I don't know if there's a proper term
for this phenomenon but I'm sure that
anyone who has travelled before and
probably knows what I'm talking about
when I first started University I used
to get that feeling all the time
I'd imagine I was back at home in high
school back then if I slept in too late
mom would send my sister Tara in to wake
me up
Tara was always the early riser between
the two of us on weekends you could
count on her being up before 9:00 every
day I was always more of the night owl
and
prefer to stay up late watching movies
and then sleep into around noon or
something but during the school week as
you can imagine how such snoozing was
allowed and Tara would be sent in to
wake me up sometimes she would even
bring our dog me to help her out at
around 15 to 20 pounds Mia was hardly a
force to be taken seriously but what
made him such an effective alarm clock
was his consistent burning desire for
attention he would jump all the way up
onto my bed run up to top of my weary
body and lick my face until finally I
mustered up the stamina to wake up and
go get ready for school the human mind
really is an amazing thing for better or
worse every week or so during my first
term I would wake up in my dorm thinking
I was back at home my old bed again I
would even hear Tara's words echo in my
head before I could peel my eyes open
eventually it stopped happening at least
for the most part I guess my mind just
grew accustomed to the fact that I'd be
staying in dorms from now on but every
now and then it still happens I'm a
sophomore now last week I had visited
home for spring break
I got back to school late last night and
immediately hit the sack before meeting
up with any of my friends and sure
enough this morning I woke with that
same old feeling
as I slowly started to wake up my eyes
remained closed as I tried to doze back
off to sleep in my mind I was home I
haven't heard my sister's words that
going through my head just like old
times
[Music]
wake up do you want to make it blade I
groaned and rolled over trying to ignore
the world around me for just a little
longer but as I started to come to soon
realized it was all in my head now I was
back at university again Terra was not
there and I could sleep in to my heart's
content but then it happened once I
realized where I was I started to fall
back to sleep and for a short while I
was relaxed
that's when I felt me you licked my face
number two creeps Nick pasta narrated my
nightmare I recently began listening to
creepypasta narrations each night before
bed now I know for some people that is
probably a terrible idea that would
likely result in a state of fear not
being able to sleep or being riddled
with terrible nightmares I even have
friends that won't watch a horror movie
past 9 p.m. for fear that they will not
be able to sleep that night if they do I
however am NOT like most people I've
been mostly desensitized to such movies
so finding a story that really scares me
is an exciting occurrence I welcome any
nightmares that may arise as you get
older it becomes very difficult to find
anything that scares you like when you
were a child sure there are worries and
stresses that come with adulthood but
real terror becomes a real rarity by the
time you hit eighth grade other than in
your dreams
so I started pulling up a creepypasta on
YouTube each night before bed and
letting it play as I closed my eyes
visualize the story in my head and hope
that if I was lucky maybe I'd get the
thrill of a nightmare ransacking my
thoughts that evening at least that's
what I thought I wanted and it's Hill
recently when I had a nightmare so
terrifying I've had to rethink my
outlook entirely see the strange thing
about horror narrations on YouTube is
that while their voices can be creepy
and unsettling they also have to be
aesthetically pleasing to listeners ears
so they also tend to have the most
soothing full sounding voices out of
anyone you might hear and what I've come
to find is that oftentimes the result is
like
lullaby and after listening to a couple
of their stories their voices can ease
you right to sleep that's another reason
that I had continued to listen to
stories before bed some of my favorite
narrators were the dark somnium lady
White Rabbit mortis media and creeps
Mecosta creeps was usually my go-to for
falling asleep as he has that relaxing
tone of voice that just puts you at ease
and makes it easy to drift off while
listening to some classic Internet
horror stories
he also uploads nearly every day so
there's usually a new video to listen to
each night which is nice every now and
then creeps will upload something known
as a compilation video which consists of
all of his narrations from that month
combined into one long video which tends
to land around four hours or so I had
fallen asleep listening to one of these
compilation videos when I discovered
what I'll call an intriguing life hack I
found that listening to a long enough
story at just the right volume can
actually result in me hearing the
creepypasta narration in my dreams this
was obviously insanely cool for me but
it didn't stop there what I discovered
was that my dreams would actually change
based on what I was hearing in the story
have you ever had someone touch or kick
you while you were asleep and have
something similar happen in your dream
as a result I imagine that it's the same
concept here only instead of a physical
response my brain was responding to the
audio needless to say I had a lot of fun
experimenting with this trick forcing
myself to have dreams of classic horror
stories creating playlists for myself so
I can control which stories play when I
enter my REM sleep cycle and getting
myself genuinely horrified when the
stories took a turn for the worst at
first if there was any kind of loud
noise or music change in the narrative
it would jolt me right awake but the
more I listened the more I became
desensitized to it after a couple of
months I was able to sleep through any
music or sound effects and creeps was
the soundtrack to my nightmares I worked
my way through the essentials until I
got tutti
JPG I had it set up so that the story
would start after 90 minutes
so basically when my dream picked up the
story had just started teeth dot jpg if
you're not familiar with it is about
four art students who live together and
come back from one summer break to one
of the roommates undergoing a strange
and disturbing behavior change what made
this experience so real for me was that
when you're in a dream you don't really
question what's going on for whatever
reason so although the characters in
this creepypasta Josh
lily and Daniel the psycho one are
completely fictional I felt like they
were my closest friends during the dream
my mind never really tried to challenge
the fact that I just lived in this world
with these characters in one of the
early scenes Daniel goes missing at
night and I as the main character of the
story end up finding the creepy teeth
dot jpg file on his computer anything I
noticed that he had a USB plugged in and
two files on the screen one was called
dentist photos and the other file was a
singular image named teeth dot jpg I
clicked on the deads
in the dream when I'm going through the
files I keep on looking over to the door
and despite the fact that I know this
story in real life it's like I don't
know what's going to happen in the
moment so I feel like Daniel is gonna
come walking in any second the strange
thing was every time I looked back at
the door
it was different the lighting outside of
change and the angle at which the door
was open was always different I would
see shadows on the wall sometimes
despite the fact that nobody was really
there that was tripping me out but in
addition to that there were a bunch of
files and Daniel's computer other than
those mentioned in the story and I
looked at them despite the fact that
creeps narration did not instruct me to
do so there were photos real photos from
my facebook page most of which were ones
that I was in me and my friends me and
my girlfriend
me and my ex-girlfriend and again at the
time I didn't realize I was dreaming I
was just taking this all at face and it
was really freaking me out I ran out of
the room and hit my foot on the floor on
the way out it really hurt it wasn't
like a dream at all the pain was so
realistic and it was pulsing through my
leg there were more strange deviations
that occurred in this dream for example
when we suspected Daniel of doing
something to Lily and went through his
bags I picked up the satchel and ended
his contents onto the coffee table I
immediately recognized the items that
poured out of the bag these were all the
same objects that I have sitting on my
nightstand
the alarm clock my phone a box of tissue
and a picture frame I reached out to
pick up my alarm clock but when my hand
got to the point of touching it I
couldn't feel anything I couldn't pick
it up since this was a dream I didn't
find this that out of the ordinary I
just felt more like I was doing
something wrong as opposed to some kind
of glitch in reality there were also
some photographs of Lily
we notice on the back of the photographs
there were labels and each tooth on each
photo was marked though notes on the
photos that said things like remove or
replace I found that these were much
easier for me to interact with and I was
able to pick up each one and inspect the
markings they were polaroid photos which
doesn't really make sense they keep back
on it but each one had Lilly's teeth
notated with permanent marker we began
searching for Lilly and it felt like we
were wandering aimlessly forever days
even it's strange how time can seem to
be uncompressed when you're dreaming
eventually we found the house
Josh kicked down the door and really
bored into the basement upon entering I
was hit with a foul odor that instantly
sickened me typically that smell had
usually been a non-factor for me in my
dreams but this just like when I banged
my foot was so real I didn't want to be
there anymore I couldn't stand to go on
but I was fighting the movement of my
own body
it was obeying each of creeps commands
which was booming over us in his calm
familiar voice and echoing all
throughout the basement I wasn't in
control anymore but I could still feel
that wretched nausea caused by that
smell I wanted to go outside and throw
up but I couldn't do that I was
continuing against my own will I looked
at Josh and he actually seemed to be
unaffected by it and it was at this
point where I think I gradually started
to realize that I was in a dream no
a nightmare that I could not wake up
from we found Lily's sweater at this
point I did actually throw up I'll avoid
the grotesque details of what happened
next as much as possible but I have to
get my point across through my own eyes
I could see the puke piling up on the
floor but how I felt was much different
than that it was like it was piling up
and wouldn't leave my mouth I started
spitting choking doing whatever I could
to prevent myself from drowning in my
own waste
but the gross nests of all of this was
making me sicker and making it clog my
mouth even more I felt like I was going
to suffocate and then somehow I was able
to clear my Airways I'm not really sure
how anyways sorry about that
no more gross parts we wandered around
in the dark someone turned on a red
light
I heard Josh scream it was probably the
loudest thing I had ever heard it was so
loud that it
where they overtook the sound of creeps
Nick Costas narrations had echoed
everywhere in the room piercing my
eardrums that felt like my head might
pop but then the echoes slowly faded out
that's when I saw Lily eyes gouged teeth
repurposed at this point I knew I was in
a nightmare
and I wanted out I tried sitting up
opening my eyes none of that worked I
heard the footsteps come up behind me I
pinched myself nothing this way that's
okay it's all for the sake of art
Daniels dialog was perfectly in sync
with the booming narration I beat my
fists against my body no luck I started
punching myself in the face no matter
what I did I couldn't wake myself up
that's when I was yanked backwards into
the dark my stomach dropped as this
happened and my eyes were blurry and
filled with tears I kicked I fought
but I couldn't make contact Daniel was
beating and bludgeoning me with what
must have been a somewhat sharp metal
post all the pain is real it was an
intense searing pain it was unlike
anything I had felt in waking or in
sleep I was bleeding I could tell
because I reached to grasp my injury and
it felt a wet and then suddenly it just
stopped as creeps gave the final
narration I could hear Lily choking I
thought I was done for but then
everything around me the entire
environment just faded away I found
myself laying in a white void I guess
it's true what they say how you can't
die in your dream
I've been laying here for what feels
like days but realistically has been
about nine hours and 15 minutes how do I
know this my alarm just went off for the
second time and it isn't waking me up
I'm starting to doubt it ever well
[Music]
number three this strange man is in all
of my dreams I'm sitting in an airport
right now
my flight is delayed so I'm going to do
my best to write this story before it's
time to board the flight have you ever
dreamed of a character who seems to only
exist in your dreams most of the
characters in my dreams are people that
I know in real life
occasionally I'll dream of a character
from a TV show or a celebrity crush but
the point is they're all people that I
can picture in my head sure there may be
one that I made up from time to time but
if that does happen they're usually only
going to appear in one dream except for
this one guy the last few years this guy
has been in almost every one of my
dreams at least the ones that I can
remember as far as I know he's never had
a name he's bald probably in his 60s or
something um I suck at guessing people's
ages he has a thin mustache and wrinkles
around his eyes yellow teeth not real
straight I wouldn't call him overweight
but he's definitely not in shape the
strange thing is this is the first time
I've been able to clearly remember what
he looks like outside of my dream but
I'll get back to that in a minute so
usually this man just shows up in random
situations in my dream like he might be
delivering me this package or if I'm
having a test dream he'll be the teacher
if I'm being chased in my dream he's
usually the malevolent pursuer if it's
getting walked in on dream he tends to
be the one to catch me so he always
plays that kind of role I don't think
I've ever held a conversation with him
in any of these
I can't really remember him talking at
all to be honest so that brings me to
today I'm flying out of Denver for work
and the flight gets delayed because of
inclement weather it's early morning and
I'm tired so I decided to nod off for a
bit in the airport now I can never
remember the beginning of my dream but
the first thing I remember was watching
my son play jak and daxter and quick
backstory I met my kid was really into
the Last of Us so I recently dug out my
old ps2 and introduced him to jak and
daxter because they're made by the same
studio and you really took a liking to
it I don't know if other people have
this happen in their dreams but I have a
lot of dreams where I'll be watching a
movie or playing a game and I kind of
gradually become one of the characters
I'm assuming I'm not the only one who
gets that so I'm in this game and I'm
exploring this area called Misty Island
I think I was supposed to be finding
this Power Cell or something I don't
remember the exact details of the
objective but me and my son were both
inside the game he kept running ahead to
explore and I would try to keep close to
him because the name of the island
suggests it was very hazy and I was
afraid he was going to get lost or
something was going to happen to him the
problem is I kept slipping on the gravel
underneath my feet it was becoming a
challenge to even stay upright he was
just kind of running around carelessly
and I lost him for a minute as he ran
around this cliff I sprinted to catch up
with him when I came around the cliff
there was nothing there
I was not only worried about my son
getting lost but also the threat of
lurkers which if you're not familiar
with the game those are their creepy
purple reptilian creatures with yellow
eyes almost on cue one of his creatures
crawled out of the cliff side crossed
right in front of me stopping me in my
tracks
they continued onward towards the shore
and disappeared in the fog
and I noticed someone's standing far in
the distance shrouded in fog I called
out my son's name but he didn't respond
he was just standing still staring at
the water I began to run up towards him
when alert the bounded from the trees
jumped and struck him in the head before
scampering off my heart sank in my chest
and I sprinted with everything I had
when I reached him I discovered it was
not my son but rather no it couldn't be
what I saw laying there in the sand was
the man from my dreams Oh lean in video
game polygon form somehow his appearance
was even creepier in compressed textures
in ps2 graphics yet the injury to his
head was terrifyingly realistic his body
then compressed into green deco in the
typical fashion of video game death
animations and he was gone I progressed
to the area that is essentially the end
of the level where I saw my son standing
up on the platform waiting for me as I
got closer I noticed there was someone
else standing there as well I'm sure
enough it was the man again he had his
hand on my son shoulder and they're both
just staring at me not knowing what to
do and I froze in my tracks before I
could come to a decision
I was jolted out of the game I was back
in my son's room staring at the blank
screen I looked over to the chair my son
had been sitting in what I saw was the
cord from his controller stretched
across the chair like he got enough and
was sitting as far back because the
cable length would allow him
I followed the stretched cable with my
eyes to meet my son's gaze but I was
instead met with an adult pair of hands
dropped the plastic controller to the
floor it was him he was just grinning at
me with the most insane stare I was
startled nearly falling back out of my
chair my first instinct was to swing my
feet around and stumble out of the room
I ran down the hall the house seemed to
be empty but strangely all of the doors
in every room
open I looked over my shoulder as I
turned the corner he'd grown about nine
feet tall his eyes were deadlocked on me
as he ducked under the doorframe exiting
my son's room and began to make his way
in my direction I went for the front
door in typical nightmare fashion it was
locked but for whatever reason I didn't
think to just reach down on a maken I
fiddled with the doorknob anxiously as I
looked over my shoulder and saw the man
walking around the corner and coming for
me with that creepy grin on his face
the doorknob fell to the ground this
thing had broken off for something as a
last-ditch effort I reared back and just
kicked the door in
what happened next is sort of difficult
to put into words I was in the car
just driving as fast as I could within
reason it was a lot like the phenomenon
I explained earlier where at first I was
watching the video game and then we are
gradually in it in this case I started
off alone in the car but at some point I
realized I was in the car with that guy
I know it doesn't make sense but in the
context of the dream I didn't question
it it wasn't making any moves or
anything literally he was just sitting
there with this stupid grin but as time
went on I was just getting more nervous
that he was about to do something I kept
looking over at him looking back at the
road then back at him I was trying to
keep an eye on him to make sure he
wasn't going anywhere
him the road him the road the next time
I looked back at him he was breathing
more and more heavily I was getting
nervous my palms were sweaty I looked
back at the road to find I'd run out of
Road I was about to drive over the edge
into the water I slammed on the brakes
but it was too late I broke through the
barrier and propelled off the edge
shiver one of those fires I started to
wake to my relief it was just all a
crazy dream just as I woke up a woman in
purple dress swiftly crossed in front of
me my gaze followed her to the window it
was almost white with fog it seemed that
there would be a significant delay until
we could take off just then I dropped my
bottle of water I had purchased before
heading to my gate
forgotten that I'd fallen asleep with in
my hand I reached down to grab it and as
I came back up
I saw something that frightened and
disturbed me the man from my dreams he
was sitting in the seat across from me
just grinning at me number four my sleep
paralysis amplified I started my new job
a few days ago well to be entirely
accurate it's not a new job I just got
transferred to another branch in another
time zone my doctor says that the stress
of having a new job new schedule and new
life are all probably contributing to my
severe sleep issues and hallucinations
I've been having ok maybe I'm getting
ahead of myself here let me take a step
back my name is Alex I'm 28 years old
and single I work for a pretty sizable
company that sells consumer and
professional-grade amplifiers to
musicians I'm the guy who makes sure you
actually get the thing he ordered and
get it on time it was recently decided
that it would be a good idea for people
like me to be close to the people who
are selling these products why they
didn't realize that in the first place
beyond me but recently I found myself
packing up and moving across the country
so I was kind of annoyed about the whole
relocation thing for the first 10
minutes of the new office I was supposed
to be meeting some of these salespeople
who I would now be working alongside
enter Caitlin luminescent light brown
eyes short but not too short brunette
hair dimples to die for I quickly got
over any annoyance I had with having to
move and started to think I was going to
like this new office by the end of the
first day Caitlin and I already had at
least three inside jokes
see I told you the copy machine
outsmarted Lenny I told her as I headed
out for the day don't worry you're not
supposed to get it it's one of our
inside jokes she laughed and told me
she'd see me tomorrow
she had such a cute laugh
sorry I got distracted there for a
second at the end of the day I was
exhausted famished
I was so eager to retire to bet but when
I laid down and shut my eyes I just
couldn't fall asleep I kept opening my
eyes and looking at the clock 1 o'clock
2 o'clock 2:30
why wasn't I falling asleep was it this
new bed was it this new apartment I
looked around my new pad and thought
about how funny it was that I still
always close my bedroom door despite
being the only one here now old habits
do die hard I suppose maybe I couldn't
sleep because I was thinking too much
maybe Kalin was on my mind too
eventually at some point I must have
dozed off but when I awoke it was still
dark out out of the corner of my eye I
saw the clock 4:23 in the morning I was
feeling pretty thirsty so I hopped up to
grab some water only when I hopped up to
grab some water my body didn't move an
inch
come to think of it I hadn't moved at
all since I had woken up I immediately
felt a wave of terror crash over me what
was going on why can't I move what's
wrong with me I was instantly overcome
with anxiety and discomfort it was like
a nightmare
where nothing happens but it was a
nightmare because nothing was happening
what if I was stuck like this forever
I will think to come check on me what if
I starve to death like this what if what
if the next thing I remember was me
waking up the next morning to my relief
I was able to get up and hit the alarm
clock now what was that last night
some kind of weird dream or was it real
it felt real but it doesn't seem real I
brought my own lunch to work that day I
opened up the fridge to find it's
completely stuffed I couldn't find an
open spot anywhere so I start to
rearrange stuff to make room what are
you doing
I hear from behind me I turned to see
this guy Jerry standing there Jerry is
the head of the sales department every
office has that guy right from what I
could tell so far in my
day here Jerry is the guy who makes you
want to take the stairs when you see him
waiting for the elevator and I might be
speaking from experience already I was
just hooked my food in your hand he
asked in the most accusatory manner I've
ever heard in my life he snatched the
bag from me I was just trying to make
space so that I could fit my lunch yeah
okay he walked away
hey no complaint from me now I had a
spot to put my lunch in throughout the
day I made sure to visit Caitlin and
make sure she wasn't overworking herself
sometimes people forget to take little
breaks I was just looking out for my
fellow employee the lack of sleep the
night before had me all worn out I was
positive that this time I would have no
trouble whatsoever with passing out I
shut my bedroom door behind me I'm
literally collapsed on my bed I
continued to lie awake for a while
though I looked at my clock periodically
11:17 1203 12 15 12 17 I was growing
restless I guess at some point though I
knocked out because a couple of hours
later I woke up in the middle of the
night again great I tried to look at the
clock but I couldn't see it from the
position I was in that's when I realized
it had happened again I couldn't move
once again I was overcome with fear was
this gonna become a regular thing
however what I saw next was about to
take my fear and amplify it my door was
open and this creature was standing in
the doorway
it was humanoid but its body was all
pitch black and it was probably seven or
eight feet tall its head was shaped like
the top of a tree stump that had been
struck by lightning and its eyes were
glowing red its mouth opening
represented a polygon with completely
random angles but the scariest part to
me for whatever reason was its fingers
each one was long in branch like
probably about two feet in length
they were just dangling there and he
well it was moving them around in a wave
motion
I tried to move I tried to scream but
what I found is that I could not even do
that it started to pace towards my bed I
could not even describe to you the
motion that used to walk it reached the
foot of the bed I was fighting with
every ounce of energy I had but my body
would not budge it came along the side
of the bed and continued to inch closer
to me I tried to scream for help and
just managed to get out the slightest
sound help I screamed out as I sat up it
was morning again I was left with the
mystery of what the sleep paralysis was
I decided it was time to see a doctor
about it and made an appointment for
after work I wasn't going to let my
rough night ruin my perfect day however
today I had a plan when I got to work
Gerry was waiting for the elevator I
smoothly redirected myself towards the
stairs and I could almost feel him
sneering at my back by the time I made
it up the stairs
Gerry was talking to Caitlin about
something luckily I saw him walk away as
I walked up I stopped and said hello to
Caitlin she flashed her infectious smile
at me sure I was tired but things were
going well I didn't bring my lunch to
work today
instead when it got to my break time I
went over to Caitlin's desk and invited
her to go grab some food with me she
delightfully accepted we got sandwiches
and we totally headed off we were
talking and cracking jokes the entire
time she does this little thing where
she'll get excited about something and
kind of bite her lip it's incredible we
got back to the office and she offered
me a mint from her drawer I accepted so
she went to open the little box of mints
and accidentally spilled a bunch of them
on the desk we both reached for the
loose mints I saw my chance and grabbed
her hand and held it in mine here and
relax I'll take care of this I told her
and used my other hand to gather the men
what's going on here I heard the stern
voice that belong to Jerry as he walked
up she quickly pulled her hands away I
finished gathering up the mints and
after taking one for myself deposited
the rest back in the container I was
taken aback by what she said next
she told him hey babe we just got back
from lunch my heart sank deep into my
chest and my head started burning up did
my ears deceive me did she really just
call Jerry the prick of the office and
her boss babe surely this must be a joke
a cruel meme of some kind he came up
behind her and kissed the top of her
head crushing whatever hope I had left
and glaring at me as he did so I
couldn't believe it
how is this idiot better than me I felt
myself starting to blush I felt so
stupid thinking she was into me she was
just being friendly
how did I not see this coming uh I gotta
get back to work she thanked me for my
company at lunch as I turned away I
could feel his glare on me so strongly
that I wish I'd worn sunscreen you went
out to lunch with that guy I heard him
ask her with an attitude as I fled the
scene great three days and I was already
making enemies the rest of my afternoon
was so hard to get through I was
constantly dozing off at my desk not
enough to fully fall asleep mind you
just enough to feel about as miserable
as I felt rejected I wanted to just go
home and sleep but I had my doctor's
appointment that evening the doc
confirmed what I pretty much already
knew I had sleep paralysis one in every
12 people get it or something he
questioned me about my lifestyle and
when he found out I had just made a big
move he was almost positive that was the
reason for my issues psychological
stress and abnormal sleep cycles are
apparently the two biggest factors that
usually contribute to it he told me that
the hallucinations are a common symptom
basically my body thinks it's a slave
ball it's awake I was supposed to see a
psychiatrist if the problem persisted
once I'd settled into my new routine
not exactly the treatment I was hoping
for but it was somewhat reassuring that
he expected me to recover on my own that
night I actually had a better time
falling asleep than before I must have
been out by 11 or 12 but that didn't
stop me from waking up in the middle of
the night again unable to move unable to
speak officially knowing that I suffered
from sleep paralysis didn't make the
experience any less scary when you have
it it feels like you're never gonna wake
up from it and the things you see feel
incredibly real and you feel incredibly
helpless that's why I wanted to scream
when I saw a knife-wielding silhouette
in my doorframe the man stepped forward
and caught a little bit of moonlight
just enough for me to identify it was
Jerry as per usual he did not look happy
to see me he tiptoed across the room to
the foot of my bed and stared me down
with disgust he continued to look at me
for about two full minutes
his body was trembling finally he came
around to the side of the bed taking an
almost identical path to the creature
from the night before he raised the
knife in the air gripping it so hard I
could see the loss of circulation to his
fingers he froze in that position almost
like he was waiting for me to make the
first move I couldn't take it the
anxiety was killing me I just wanted him
to do it already didn't get it over with
the last thing I could remember them as
him stuck in that position trembling
like a maniac morning came I turned off
my alarm clock and the post nightmare
relief felt incredible as it dawned on
me I actually felt pretty decent for
once not back to where I was before the
moon but not 100% exhausted either it
was Friday
so I thought maybe I'd have the energy
to go out into town and explore my new
city after work tonight maybe it would
help get my mind off things I hopped out
of bed and as I began to get dressed I
realized something
something that flushed whatever optimism
or relief I had away something that made
my body and legs
lock up just as they had the two
previous nights something that made my
heart sink deep into my chest just as it
had when I found out about Kaitlyn and
Jerry what I realized was my bedroom
door was open
[Music]
thank you for snoozing in with us in all
daint a sleepy pasta I did this collab
with the dark somnium he's a massively
underrated horror narrator if you like
all dainty creepypasta and if you
appreciate the original music a
cinematic sound design in the quality
graphic design you should seriously
consider going over to subscribe to his
channel he is all about that stuff and
always does great work when I started
all dainty creepypasta in October I
wanted to fill a void where I saw room
for improvement in the genre and
hopefully inspire some others to go the
extra distance as well so it's great to
see the dark somnium pulling off these
high standards of quality and I'd love
to see him get recognition for it as
well while I was making this video I
actually fell asleep and had this
nightmare where we were doing the dead
stream beyond the inner horror podcast
that I do with Lady White Rabbit and
mortis media and everything just kept
going wrong I couldn't get the
animations to play correctly and there
was all this background noise and
interruptions I guess these are the kind
of things that youtubers have nightmares
about the other thing that we have
nightmares about is you the viewers not
getting notified about our uploads so
please make sure you're subscribed and
make sure that your death Bell
notifications are on subscribing
honestly does nothing unless you click
that little bell next to the subscribe
button I don't know why it's like that
now but you have to take that extra step
otherwise you'll be missing out on new
Horrors every week I will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]